[Music]
you know i wake up naturally looking
like this with this hair and makeup this
is just how i wake up beautiful oh it's
like the all-american girl very
sweet and not too sexy
before she was the face of balenciaga
kim kardashian was modeling bongo what
girl wouldn't want to be in the bongo ad
and that's where e.t first met the
budding entrepreneur it's a big day it's
a big shoe this is like the thing that i
love to do the most the clothes are so
cute and the jeans they actually fit me
really well it's hard for me to find
jeans when i see ad campaigns especially
you know jean ads when you see girls
that are so skinny i cannot fit in half
of those jeans my sisters and my mom
everyone kind of jokes around with me
and tells me to stop eating this or that
but you know what i am who i am and i i
love that i'm not skinny i love my
curves i like to you know show off that
you don't have to be stick skinny to be
a model the year was 2007. kim and her
famous family just launched keeping up
with the kardashians
that's it we're done
i'm there with my entire family it's
like how much better can that be we're
having so much fun it's like it's not
work but kim was still getting used to
her sex symbol status i'm gonna do
playboy
what made you decide to pose for playboy
again to show people that you don't have
to be stick skinny i'm proud of my
curves and and who i am and
you know i just wanted to show people
that you can be proud of yourself too
you don't want to be like too sexy you
know you don't want people to not be
able to relate to you or that's all that
they think of you as i'm actually really
kind of like goofy and nerdy and i kind
of just stay home i'm not this like sexy
person that everyone thinks i am the
princess is in the building
people don't know that i'm the best cook
like i could be a chef if i wanted to
the reason we wanted to do a reality
show was there's i just feel like
there's so many different stereotypes of
what hollywood kids are like and i think
me and my sisters are completely the
opposite of that so to have cameras show
people that we don't shop all day and
party all night you know we get up i
have my store that i run dash and it's
like there's so many things we have
going on it's just kind of good to give
people you know a taste of what we're
really like
at the time the then 27 year old was
still dealing with the aftermath of her
leaked sex tape
it's kind of hard to explain because you
you think you do something in private
and then the whole world sees something
and you're not prepared for it this is
our way to tell our story how it really
happened
because i feel like you know with all
the tabloid magazines and so many
different people make up different
stories that's the perfect way to
tell the truth and show people what
really goes on when you have your family
and the you know people that you are
surrounded by know you and who you are
it makes everything so much better i've
learned not to care
well one thing we care about who kim
told us was her celeb crush back then my
hollywood crush is george clooney
he's so cute he just gets better with
age
[Music]